and a warning there is flash photography
from the start
[Applause]
protests across several russian cities
and here in moscow against mobilization
and the habitual response from police
[Applause]
[Music]
these protests will be crushed and
hundreds detained
as you can see here pretty dramatic
scenes and bear in mind we haven't seen
protests
in cities for the last five or six
months people have been so scared of the
fact that they will be detained and that
is clearly what is happening
this partial mobilization of 300 000 men
so far was something the kremlin had
said it would never do
announced in a special address to the
nation the president flanked by the
symbols of the russian state with yet
another warning to the west
to defend russia and our people we will
certainly make use of all weapon systems
available to us
this is not a bluff
the citizens of russia can rest assured
that the territorial integrity of our
motherland
our independence and freedom will be
defended i repeat
by all the systems available to us
those who are using nuclear blackmail
against us should know that the wind can
turn their way
then from the defense minister the
detail fleshed out a bit
this is not about people who've never
seen or heard about the army
this is about those who first of all
have served in the army secondly have
the military expertise needed today in
the armed forces and also those who have
combat experience
now this horrendous fight in
neighbouring ukraine comes that bit
closer to home
students aren't being taken yet
we hope everything is going to be okay
i want peace i don't want war
i don't want any war
it's horrible and scary i have a friend
who died there
yeah i think it's a total disgrace
my friend is a contractor he's at the
border at the moment he will basically
die
i don't want the guys who are getting
enlistment papers to go there too and
other died should be protected from
fascists as it was in the second world
war as it is now who will do it if not
us
this sign speaks for him and for many
here but it does not speak for everyone
from his jail cell russia's most famous
prisoner alexei navalny condemned what
he called putin's crimes
putin is tormenting a neighboring
country killing people there
now he's throwing into the grinder of
war a huge amount of russian citizens
who have to live normally and take care
of their families of course it was a
crime but now it has become the crime of
a much bigger scale
now sweeps up more ordinary russian
citizens and makes it harder for the
kremlin to claim as it has done for so
long now that everything is going to
plan